scottish independence all sides agreed
that the mata had been settled
in 2014 for a generation after the first
referendum
do you just keep holding them until you
get your own way
and everybody accepted the result after
2014 you know
the evidence of that is scotland is not
independent but support for independence
in scotland has
continued to increase since 2014 it's
now i think most polls would tell us the
majority
position in scotland and of course the
other point here is that things
change pretty dramatically after 2014
the brexit referendum
whereby scotland has been taken out of
the eu against our will
really changed fundamentally the nature
of the
uk and actually in 2014 one of the key
arguments the no campaign made was that
voting no was essential to protect our
eu membership and the opposite turned
out to be true if brexit changed things
has the pandemic shifted sentiment again
and blunted
the argument for a referendum because
actually for many scots the priority is
on
sorting out the pandemic throughout the
pandemic we've actually seen support for
independence in scotland and opinion
polls
increase the opinion polls show that
actually the country is very very
divided on the match of independence you
don't have a clear
momentum for independence it's it's very
very evenly
well actually i think you cannot
objectively come to the
view that there has not been a marked
increase in support for independence
since 2014 that there has been
i think the polling evidence suggests
now a majority of scots who want
independence but yes there's a
significant number who don't and that
comes back to this point in a democracy
how do you settle that you settle that
by letting people decide
and on a constitutional issue that has
to be through
a democratic legal legitimate referendum
i go to your road map for a referendum
you say
it should be held after the pandemic at
a time to be decided by the
democratically elected scottish
parliament
what's your time frame on this if the
pandemic
allows it then i think scotland should
have a choice
and i've said if it allows it in the
first half of the parliamentary term
that is
you know a two and a half year period is
the snp a single issue party
uh no and i don't think anybody that
knows anything about scottish politics
could
make that argument we are a party
that social and economic policy wise or
a progressive party that is about
building a better scotland we just think
independence is a key part
just be careful a vote for the snp in
this
election is a vote for independence
isn't it i vote for the snp in this
election is firstly a vote for
experienced leadership to get us through
covert
secondly it's a vote for that
progressive bold
transformational policy program that
we're putting forward
to kick start and drive recovery and yes
then after the pandemic
it's a vote to give people the choice of
independence
in a referendum but if you were if you
were pro nicholas sturgeon
and pro nicolas sturgeon being first
minister but not pro-independence
you vote against independence in a
referendum vote for you could you
because you wouldn't want the referendum
that you're trying to put on the table
plenty people do but voters do need to
be clear that if they vote
i think the smp they are going to with
respect
i think i think most people who live in
scotland are very clear about the snp
okay let's just move on to the the
mandate for the referendum
you say again in your roadmap that if
the snp takes office the scottish
government will again request a section
30 order from the uk government
believing and publicly contending that
in such circumstances
there could be no moral or democratic
justification for denying that request
but but that's not how prime minister
johnson sees it isn't it he won't grant
you
this referendum you're stark well no
actually it's the people of scotland
who'll decide their future she would say
that you well if you have a referendum
in 2014
if you know if you wanted to speak for
boris johnson i know you're not speaking
for boris johnson but of course he would
say that
i know that i'm sorry my apologies of
course he will say that
um but that doesn't make him right and
what we set out in the
the root map is that if we win the
election then we will bring forward the
legislation
and if boris johnson wants to challenge
that
legally which is what he would have to
do then we will rigorously and
vigorously defend the position
against that challenge just to go over
what you see you're saying that um
you then expect boris johnson
to grant the referendum no what i would
expect boris johnson to do
and i you know the fact that this is a
controversial statement perhaps speaks
volumes what i would expect boris
johnson to do is to respect the
democratic decision
of the people of scotland why should
that in any way be controversial
but if he doesn't what does he do i just
told you if boris johnson wanted to stop
it he would have to take legal action
and we would defend that look so you
would then hold just to be clear because
so people on so you then could hold an
advisory referendum without consent from
the uk
no if if boris johnson didn't do that
then by definition it would be a legal
referendum if he did do that the courts
would
decide but actually we're getting ahead
of ourselves here because
i believe that if the people of scotland
vote for this if support for
independence continues to increase
then it is not sustainable for any
westminster prime minister
to stand in its way and you talk to
people in the uk i i understand
and i understand you know i don't see
how you make it happen well
genuinely well you can say it's
unsustainable but
because it's unsustainable but if you
just exist
you know what you do you know probably
better than i do because you speak to
people in the uk government
presumably regularly but i know because
i hear this from within the uk
government they're already considering
what they do in these circumstances
because they know they can't stand in
the way
of a clear democratic demand of the
scottish people
you would hold a referendum even if you
don't get
can i can i respectfully suggest that
you read what we've set out
i i did read it i just don't see how
you're going i'm not sure
johnson well you know boris johnson is
not somebody who is immune to democracy
no
prime minister is immune to democracy
even boris johnson
you know this argument that people in
scotland can vote for that they can
demand a referendum they can vote for
the snp
over and over again but somehow a
westminster prime minister can simply
stand in its way is not going to be
sustainable but also
in the process perhaps makes the biggest
argument for independence that there is
just one you said uh about alex some
there were serious questions about the
appropriateness of his political combat
that he was his ego
stopping him from leaving the public
stage no look i
trusted alex hammond for a long long
time um
and i have found out things about alex
almond since then that have made me
question not just my
faith and trust in him but his fitness
uh for
returning to to public office would you
work with alex salmond and alba
to get uh
before that party was even in existence
okay so you know i've got no intentions
of doing that the polling would suggest
so you wouldn't want
but i've made my position clear and the
polling suggests it's a hypothetical
question but i'm in this election
concentrating
on putting forward the positive snp case
work with whom you wouldn't i
i've said what i've said i am focused on
the snp
winning a majority um and being
re-elected to government
on the issue of second referendum if you
don't manage to secure it would you view
that as your political career ending in
failure
look i'm in an election campaign the
post suggests that the snp right now is
on track
to win could the may election be a game
changer for scottish independence
look we have an opportunity for it to be
a game changer for scottish politics
for the last 10 years we've provided
politics in scotland that is
all about what divides us rather what
unites us we have an opportunity to do
politics differently
and that's why i want us to come through
this election with a better government
and a better opposition
focusing on what unites us and focusing
on a national recovery but just in terms
of what the outcome is
likely to be or could be if the snp
do win a majority does that give
nicholas dodge and the smp
a mandate to call a second referendum
i'm not gonna
commentate on what might happen in the
result but it would give her it would
give her the ability to claim a mandate
if she wins the majority
having campaigned on having a second
referendum it's a mandate isn't it
but what that exposes in even more stark
terms
is the choice people face in this
election campaign we can
either choose to have our parliament
focus on the next five years
and on that stushie between but if they
choose nicola sturgeon it gives them a
mandate doesn't it i think scotland can
choose something different
the challenge that you have is nicola
sturgeon has been on the front trying to
lead us through this pandemic but she
has a blind spot
her blind spot is the constitution she
is honestly trying to tell people in
scotland
that we come through this collective
trauma of code and we just go back to it
but i'm not i'm just not just kidding
i'm just asking you really
i get that but i'm just asking you
really basically you asked me about the
game changing
i'm telling you what game changer is but
i'm asking a very basic question which
is
if nicola station
right thing for available coming through
this pandemic whether or not you
think independence is a good or bad idea
do you accept the principle that it is
for the people of scotland
to decide that look of course i accept
the principle that it's for the people
of scotland to decide their future and
that's why they're voting in this
election campaign
i don't believe the smp's gonna have a
majority coming through this election
campaign i'm arguing for something
different
i'm arguing for us to have in your own
words a game changer let's change the
frame of scottish politics
and actually changing the frame of
scottish politics gives us the
opportunity to set the frame of uk
politics
so so just so in principle you accept
that it's right that the scottish people
decide on their future you're not really
saying whether you think nicola sturgeon
has a mandate or not for
for a second ref you sound a bit like uh
jeremy corbyn in the 2019 election
talking about brexit well i have no idea
what he thinks i've got to say i've
never been accused of that before so
there is a first time for everything
what i'm saying is my position on
independence in a referendum is clear
i don't support independence i don't
support referendum
i'm standing in this election to say
let's choose something different
if the snp win a majority in hollywood
they do or don't have a mandate for a
second referendum i don't believe the
smp are going to win a majority but if
they do this election campaign if they
don't i am a participant
i'm not a spectator but do you accept
they have a mandate so
it's easier it's easier for you to
commentate on the election i'm a
participant i want to i want scotland to
choose something different but but why
won't you answer the question
which question whether or not um snp
majority gives
a mandate to call a second referendum
because what i'm saying to people it's
the most important
issue what i'm saying is i'm going to
argue for what i believe
and i don't believe independence or a
referendum is right for scotland
so you don't i'm going to i'm going to
continue to argue for what i believe
but not unless people say whether or not
they have a mandate
for me let people cast their votes in
the sixth season they don't have a
mandate
well not a single vote has been cast yet
in this election but do you accept that
if nicolas sturgeon wins the majority
that the second referendum question is
going to dominate scottish politics for
the next five years
that's the risk isn't it and that and
that's what i'm saying directly to
people in scotland
is this is the risk we face of the next
five years
we have a different choice and the
choice we have is we can have a strong
opposition in this country a better
opportunity but you're not a strong
doesn't it
does it have to be douglas but labor
isn't it isn't part of the problem that
labour hasn't been a strong opposition
that labour has let unionists down the
challenge is
saying to people if you agree with what
i'm seeing if you like what i'm saying
if you want the game changer beth
the word that you used i'm going to
start using that more often this
campaign as well if you want that game
changer
then vote labour in this election how
worried are you
that on a five-year time frame that
scotland will become an independent
country
i think scotland will choose something
different when you say scotland will
choose something different
you mean in the holyrood election or do
you mean
in an independence referendum that
they'll choose to stay i'm talking about
the choice that scotland faces on the
sixth of me
isn't it isn't it wishful thinking uh to
think that nicola sturgeon is not going
to win a majority
not at all i don't think anything is
inevitable in this contest i
i know other politicians might want to
think it's inevitable um i'm not being
as arrogant as that to suggest that if
something's inevitable
no one has yet cast their vote and
people can have a choice to choose
something different in this election
campaign
douglas ross could the hollyrood
elections
be a game changer for scottish
independence
well clearly we've got two nationalist
parties be it nicholas sturgeon's
nationalists or alex salmons
nationalists who are seeking to
dominate the whole of scottish politics
once again with another independence
referendum and
what i'm saying and scottish
conservatives are saying is we need to
put that threat
away we need to get rid of that today to
allow us to focus on our recovery and
rebuilding after covid
whether you think independence is a good
idea or bad idea do you accept the
principle
that it's right for the scottish people
to decide that
well the scottish people did decide that
of course back in 2014 we were told then
by nicolas sturgeon and the snp
that referendum was the gold standard of
referendums they would abide by the
result
of the people of scotland more than 2
million scots 55
said they wanted to remain part of the
united kingdom
if pro-independence parties win a
majority
in hollywood do you accept the principle
that they should be able to hold
another referendum or do you just want
to block it full star
well as a conservative and unionist i
don't want another damaging divisive
independence referendum
would uh johnson government ever
authorize a second independence
referendum well
again i've said conservatives are
against another independence referendum
but we know the threat of holding
another independence referendum
if the snp win a majority now scottish
conservatives stopped them getting that
majority
in 2016. five years ago at that election
we more than doubled the number of very
good
majority it's a game changer then isn't
it but if they win a majority it's a
game-changer there's a way to stop that
majority
if but all the polling suggests that
they are going to win a majority becomes
the game change
but the polling is very close at the
moment the s p only need four extra
seats to get that majority to take us
through another damaging divisive
independence referendum
but we can stop that and the way we
stopped it five years ago was people
uniting behind the strongest pro-uk
party the scottish conservatives by
giving
us their votes on the party-less vote
stop that snp majority and stop that
damaging device but you're acknowledging
in that very answer that if the snp win
a majority then there will be an
argument they will have a right to push
for that referendum because that's what
they've been elected on well people
are people have given them the majority
for it so people absolutely have to
understand that is the risk of voting
snp
nikola sturgeon is trying to say it's
about the way she's handled this
pandemic or about other policies she's
bringing forward
but a vote for the snp is a vote to
divide our country again
and hold another independence referendum
to separate scotland from the uk
how's brexit change things though i
think many people see the uncertainty
with brexit and don't want to go through
all that again with scottish
independence look at how difficult it
was to come out of a union we'd been
part of for 40 plus
years rather than a union where i was
thinking of 300 i was thinking of it
rather on the basis that a conservative
uh government in westminster took
scotland out of the european union
when scottish voters wanted to remain in
a bit more
that's quite hard for scots to take
isn't it a bit more than about johnson
took them out of the eu
when nearly two to one scottish
people did not want that to happen but
more than a million people in scotland
did vote to lead the european union and
when we voted in 2016 we knew it was
part of a uk
sanctuary two percent of scottish people
wanted to remain in the european union
do you not think that nicola sturgeon
and the snp have an argument to say
that scottish people are not being
represented by this government
we knew in 2016 the votes taken in
scotland england wales and northern
ireland
would be combined together for a uk
result whether to leave
or stay in the eu where i don't feel
uncomfortable is just looking at our
vaccination role out here in scotland
and across the uk
no but that that is something that works
it was a paradigm shift
that is something we have been able to
do as a result of brexit
if the snp do win a majority in
hollywood what do you
say to the prime minister about what you
do next well i'm not going to focus on
that i think there's a strong
opportunity to stop that s p majority by
people
coming behind the scottish conservatives
that tried and tested model
that stopped an s p majority five years
ago and then we can get rid of the
question of another independence
referendum and focus on our recovery but
you can only change the focus of
scottish politics away from a second
referendum
if the snp are not the major party here
and do not win hollywood and it looks
like they are going
to so if it does happen how does
the prime minister of the united kingdom
try and stop a second refreshers do you
just say that we're not doing it
well it's really hard to
expect me to concede an election before
the votes have been
cast before they've been counted and
before we've seen an opportunity
again as we did in 2016 for the scottish
conservatives to stop that snp majority
we can focus on the other issues you're
not going to be able to stop it though
but people said that back in 2016
remember the snp went into that election
with a majority and how important then
is this election
i mean it's it's massive and i've said
the future of our country
is at stake is that crystal clear that
is the
issue at stake at this election when we
can park that issue when we can stop
that snp majority
then we can focus on recovery and all
the other issues that most people in
scotland want their parliament to be
focused on is the prospect of
scotland becoming independent do you see
it as a realistic possibility
well it worries me for for my you know
i've got a two-year-old boy i want him
to to grow up in a scotland and a uk
that i did and all the opportunities
i had and i don't think we will help the
next generation by
separating from the united kingdom the
most powerful and successful economic
and political union the world has ever
seen so
there are so many positives of working
together of uniting
of being one family of four nations
building together
in good times and bad working together
through a pandemic
and i think there are many opportunities
to come and that's all put a threat
with the risk of another independence
referendum and
this is the list of parties and their
leaders or lead candidates standing
across scotland at the elections this
thursday
more details about your constituency and
the candidate standing there
can be found on your local council web
pages